well the answer is we want to call this
car function in the same context as the
new van instance that's been created
right there since that's being stored in
the parameter this we can just pass this
along and run the car function in the
same context as the van function is
being called we can get rid of this
pretend line of code because it was only
there to remind us what was going to
take place as a result of using the
keyword new this is exactly how we want
to call the car function from within the
van function such that it operates on
the right context but people seem to
find this line of code extremely
confusing so let's take a look at it for
a moment